so first of all we've got the product of
powers and basically all this is saying
is that if you have two quantities that
have the same base see this bottom
number is called the base raised to a
power and you're multiplying them
together that's what product means it
means you're multiplying all you do is
you just add the exponents together you
keep the base the same so let's look at
some examples so if you have x squared
times X cubed see x squared is really
like two X's X cubed is really like
three X's multiplied together and you
can see you have a total of five X's
that's X to the fifth
but the shortcut is you just say two
plus three is five X to the fifth okay
this one here you can see we've got 2x
squared times 3x to the fifth so we're
gonna multiply two times three which is
six x squared times X to the fifth you
can see we have the same base so we're
gonna add two plus five that gives us X
to the seventh so just remember you keep
the base and when you're multiplying you
just add the exponents that's the
product of powers okay the next one is
the power of a power so you can see what
we have is we have e to the M this whole
thing raised to the N power so you have
an exponent raised to another exponent
or they call it a power to a power and
what you do here is you multiply the
exponents together you keep that same
base but you multiply the exponents so
an example here would be like x squared
cubed now I'll show you why it works
see when you cube something that means
you have three of them right and x
squared means you have two of those and
you can count these all up and you can
see we've got six X's all multiplied
together so it's X to the sixth but the
shortcut is you just say two times 3 is
6 so X to the sixth okay so power to
power you just multiply now we've got
power of a product but a product just
means that these two quantities are
multiplied together this is a call to
monomial it's just mono means one like
one term all raised to a power and you
can see what you're doing is you're
actually distributing that power to each
of the quantities here on the inside so
let's look at some examples you've got X
Y cubed what you would do is you would
distribute that power so you can see
that's going to be X cubed Y cubed now
this one here going to distribute the 3
to the 2 to the x squared and to the Y
cubed now you don't see it but this 2
actually has an exponent of 1 so it's
going to be 1 times 3 which is 2 cubed 2
times 3 which is X to the sixth 3 times
3
is why to the ninth now two cubed is
eight so we can write this as eight X to
the sixth Y to the ninth okay let's go
to the quotient of powers now
so quotient means that you're dividing
and you can see that what we're going to
do here is that when we divide we
subtract the exponents we take the
numerators power minus the denominators
power okay
so let's look at an example so X to the
seventh divided by X cubed now X to the
seventh I'll just show you why this
works X to the seventh means that you
have one two three four five six seven
X's all multiplied together divided by X
cubed which is three X's and you can see
that these are cancelling one another
out or anything divided by itself
there's one and you can see we're left
with one two three four X's multiplied
together which is X to the fourth but
that's the long way to do it you just
want to use the shortcut which is you're
going to subtract seven minus three
which is four and you keep that base the
same X to the fourth let's look at
another example here we've got 5x cubed
over 10 X to the first now the five over
ten you can just reduce this like a
normal fraction that's going to be one
half three minus one is two and where
some students make a little mistake as
they get confused they say do I put that
in the denominator do I put it in the
numerator you always put that result in
the numerator so you say X cubed okay
divided by X to the first three minus
one is two X square goes in the
numerator one times anything is itself
so you could just write this as x
squared over two
all right now the power of a potion so a
quotient just means that you're dividing
two quantities and you're raising them
to a power right so that's the power
part so quotient raised to a power and
all you do here is you distribute that
power to the numerator and the
denominator okay so let's look at some
examples so here going to distribute the
four to the numerator and the
denominator power to a power we multiply
so two times four gives us X to the
eighth three times four gives us Y to
the twelfth so pretty simple you just
distribute to the numerator and the
denominator a little bit more
challenging one you're going to
distribute the two to the three and
that's something that students often
forget they forget to distribute to the
number as well as the variable okay and
same thing here and you can also
distribute the two to this three and to
this five so 3 squared is 9 two times
two gives you X to the fourth five
squared is 25 and three times 2 is y to
the sixth so power to power you just
multiply the
exponents together okay now we're going
to the zero power property and that's
that anything to the zero power equals
one and if you want to understand that a
little bit better
just take a simple example like say you
had X cubed divided by X cubed well when
you use the quotient rule right from up
here when you divide what you do you
subtract so that's going to be three
minus three which is zero and this
property tells us that anything to the
zero power is one but it makes sense
from the standpoint of you can see this
is X cubed divided by X cubed anything
divided by itself is one okay so you can
see how that works there but if you see
your X to the zero this would be one and
then this one here sometimes tricks
students a little bit but it's this
whole quantity raised to the zero power
it looks like there's more that needs to
be done but really since this whole
thing is being raised to the zero power
the answer is just one okay and then the
last one here we're talking about
negative exponents and you can see here
a to the negative M power is equal to 1
over e to the positive n power now a lot
of students make the mistake of thinking
that when it's a negative exponent that
makes the number negative or the base
negative but it doesn't the negative
exponent is really just a symbol that
tells us to take the reciprocal or to
move this quantity to the other side of
the fraction bar and then you make it a
positive exponent so let's look at some
examples X to the negative 2 is the same
as 1 over X to the positive 2 okay let's
look at this a little bit more
challenging so 5 over 20 that reduces to
1/4 and you can see X to the negative 2
what I'm going to do is I'm just going
to take this quantity I'm going to move
it to the other side of the fraction bar
okay so when you have a negative
exponent just move it to the other side
if it's in the denominator move it to
the numerator if it's in the numerator
move it to the denominator this power of
this rule with the negative exponent
just tells us to take the reciprocal
that's going to move it from one side of
the fraction bar to the other the Y is a
positive exponent we're just gonna leave
that where it is and then the Z to the
negative fifth that's a negative
exponent we're going to move that to the
other side of the fraction bar since
it's been denominator were going to move
it up to the numerator and make it a
positive 5 so your goal is when you're
all done you want to just have positive
exponents and that's what we have here
so I hope this helped you understand how
to work with the rules of exponents a
little bit better
subscribe to the channel check out some
more math videos on Mario's math tutor
YouTube channel I look forward to seeing
the future videos I'll talk to you soon